yo what is up everybody this procedure
man luigi's with another Borderlands the
pre-sequel video and today we're going
to be doing another class setup for the
law bringer Nisha they see I'm playing
Nisha again I'm level 60 and I got my
chronicler chronicler chronic color
chronic color color chronic color of
alphas class mod which is one of the
class mods you can get from the halidome
so this is gonna be kind of more of an
update of way should spend your new six
skill ten skill point from the ultimate
vault hunter mode uh and it's going to
be incorporating into the previous build
of Nisha that I have and if you want to
check that out i have a video up and you
can go click that and that'll show you
the where you put the first 48 skill
points and you'll see here i have the
first 48 skill points set up and
actually actually I'm missing one so I
must have placed one incorrectly so I'm
just gonna put one order but so this is
so this is easy this build is going to
be one point off because I only am using
9 what because I I put one in like this
or this when I should have put it in
order so you can see this is the bill
that I have for my previous Nisha build
when you only worked a little 50 and the
addition of the chronicler of elpis uh I
don't know what to call it class is
gonna be slightly different you see this
is actually what are we called I'm gonna
call it like the no shoot no scope it's
going to be the no scope build so you
can see that the chronicle up elpis
gives you + act like extra faster and
you High Noon trickshot tombstone and no
pain no gain now we really don't go into
this tree so we're not going to get no
pain no gain and faster new and high
noon we're both already a part of this
nisha build so I put like two points in
each because they get + 4 + + 4 from a
level 59 60 chronicler class mod so what
this is really going to be focus
son you're going to add tombstone and
you're going to add trick shot at so
tombstone after you kill enemy all of
your shots have a chance hit as critical
this will kill much faster and trick
shot bullets that hit balls other
objects have a chance to Rick [ __ ] off
toward a nearby enemy and this gives you
a plus for this is really good for the
boxy but it is good for a lot of so
you're going to put let's hit put two in
there put two in there put 1111 and then
you would have enough to do one each
however I messed it up so like how you
take one out of like on a bottle courage
and put in here so I'm just gonna put in
trick shot since I do value trickshot
more than tombstone and that is the max
that I have for trick shop so that
smacks a tombstone is one away from the
next step so what's cool about this
build is that whenever you go and fight
enemies um you really don't have to aim
it then let it alone like scope in and
just like try hard to kill him I Girardi
nisha so you don't have to do that but
like when your shots will just bounce
off and just hit enemies like I showed
you guys with kragens in the my
Christmas episode this gun and this guy
i'm using right now i think i had the
chronicler of elpis noscope build and
yet so that's the build i hope you guys
have enjoyed this video i'm not gonna do
any gameplay since I really actually
have to go I'm rushing to make this
video so I do hope you have enjoyed make
sure you check out my other Borderlands
content if you had not and like you
haven't seen that previous build video
go check it out it's on my channel and
I'll see you all later peace out guys